ask yourself this honestly did you ever
think that in life you would see a movie
that stars both Donald Sutherland and
Lenny Kravitz and it's a drama The
Hunger Games Catching Fire is directed
by Francis Lawrence and stars Jennifer
Lawrence the same last name getting off
topic already the sign of a great film
reviewer it also stars Josh Hutcherson
Liam Hemsworth Philip Seymour Hoffman
Donald Sutherland Jena Malone Jeffrey
Wright there's a huge cast in this movie
of extremely talented people and they
are all assembled for this giant
franchise sequel to make sequel Hunger
Games is a humongous success financially
critics liked it people liked it certain
things about the book to movie
translation did bother some fans that's
always it's just that's going to happen
all the time so in this movie we get a
much better look at the Capitol this
evil government that controls people
uses people to star in The Hunger Games
and in this film
Katniss played by Jennifer Lawrence and
Peeta played by just Hutchison are
forced back into another Hunger Games
because of some random newly written
rule because this government is so
against these people
this government just wants to see
Katniss and Peeta fail at everything
they want to use them to control people
as well by influencing them to do
various things and all they want to do
is try to figure out a way to get these
people out of there the best way they
can think to do that is to start another
Hunger Games and force winners of
previous Hunger Games to be involved now
what I heard from a lot of people was
that this film is going to be a lot more
dark than the first one because the
second book is more dark than the first
one and sometimes in movies I hear that
all the movie is so much darker than the
first one or oh it's so much more
intense more violent this movie truly is
more dark than the first one in the best
type of way because it's not a film
that's more dark simply because it's
more violent or there's more forced
scenes of sadness where they think well
we're gonna add this and this and this
to make it seem more dark this film has
real genuine emotion where I actually
really cared for these characters they
felt sincere and honest and as the movie
progresses and things happen and you
watch these characters go through
everything you could possibly think of
that's horrible you're just like that
sucks man but like I said the characters
in this movie felt so authentic they
felt like real
people Jennifer Lawrence was terrific as
Katniss again she is a great actress
we've figured this out she's great she's
good in the movie she's very good here
Josh Hutcherson I thought did a lot
better than he did in the first film and
that was one of my problems with the
first one was I don't mind him as an
actor I just I didn't really feel like
he was that much of a real emotional
presence and this filming gave a much
better performance without a much more
mature performance and not just because
his character is more mature he felt
like he was giving just a better
performance overall than he did in the
first movie good job situations in this
movie that are created by the Capitol
and forced upon the people get
increasingly more sadistic to the point
where you're like dude this is horrible
there were images in this movie that
felt very reminiscent of the Holocaust
where the Nazis stormed places where
Jewish people were living in other
religions that Hitler didn't like there
were visual elements of that in this
film where the officers of the Capitol
were going around and storm people's
houses and taking people out of the
streets and dumping other belongings out
and you really could tell that there was
definitely some influence there from
that and it made it all the more
horrific and that's one of the pluses of
this movie is the fact that the
villainous aspect of it felt more like a
presence because in the first film I get
it they were bad people and you know you
felt like this sucks like this whole
thing sucks like why are these people
forced to do this this really sucks I'm
sorry I keep using that it is not good
it's not good and you felt it but in
this film you got to see the behind the
scenes of why these people are doing the
things they do why they make the
decisions they make and it made the
whole antagonist of this movie which is
basically all of the capital it just
felt more like a presence of evil it was
kind of like in the first Star Wars
movie you know you got Darth Vader okay
he was evil he was awesome he was really
cool he was a bad guy you got the
stormtroopers who can't aim and shoot at
anything to save their lives but he
didn't really see the Empire and the
whole inner workings of it and how it
all came together until the Empire
Strikes Back which is kind of like
Catching Fire
you really got a great in-depth look at
the bad guys in this movie and that's
one of the reasons why I felt the drama
was so much more rich in this film it
was very exciting too there was a lot of
really good action sequences once the
Hunger Game starts because I can tell
you when the Hunger Games were coming up
to a start my heart was
started to race I was really into it
because they lead you up to that so well
by enriching the characters and making
you feel more for these people making
you feel like yes I really really care
about these fictional people and that's
one of the reasons why the Hunger Games
themselves work so well because you're
already at a point where you really want
these people to succeed in some way and
you want to see these bad guys go to a
place that's not happy I saw this movie
with a friend of mine his name is Craig
candy ko and he runs a website called
fat movie guy comm it's a pretty funny
website but he writes great reviews and
one of the parallels he mentioned after
this movie was how realistic it portrays
the whole news and media world and the
way they look at stars and celebrities
because we saw a red carpet show before
the screening they broadcast the LA
premiere and the way everyone was like
oh my god what are you wearing oh what
still shoes what's that bag and it's
basically just rich people biessing and
trying to promote their stuff that's
really all it is
and the movie really played on that very
well with the scan Lee Chi Chi character
who is great in the movie once again and
that's one of the reasons why these
books and this movie are very successful
because you really feel a relation to
real life and it has a lot of things to
say about the way the government works
about media and it's all in there in the
Hunger Games and teen girls love it
because there's a love triangle and blah
blah blah but you know it actually has a
lot of things to say another huge
improvement I thought over the first
film which don't get me wrong I actually
enjoyed was the directing Francis
Lawrence gave a much more fluid solid
look to this movie it felt epic it felt
big it felt long but in a good way it
didn't feel too long you felt like you
were experiencing just the right amount
of time for these big elements in this
movie and it really paid off he did a
great job setting up the games setting
up the characters the movie looked so
much better there wasn't as much shaky
care in fact there was barely any it is
sad it is dark but it is an entertaining
fun movie and you really get behind the
character of Katniss and Jennifer
Lawrence as I said does a great job in
this movie this movie really surprised
me I thought it was much better than the
first film which was still a film that I
enjoyed I'm gonna give the Hunger Games
Catching Fire and a - it was an intense
movie I really felt for these characters
and I think they did a great job for
this one I'm looking forward to the next
one so guys when you do see the movie or
if you have already let me know if you
think it honors the book if you are a
huge fan of the book
are you happy are you upset that they
let certain things out or are you happy
with the things they took out thanks as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes